yeah just slipped over into the studio
you know I got some chairs coming I was
gonna try to have a guest today and
couldn't get it couldn't couldn't get
chairs in time to be lined up and
ordered some chairs and they got two
chairs coming and so you know it's nice
when you have them chairs coming you
know when you got because if you have a
chair eventually you have a place to put
somebody because that's the thing if
you're just standing around with
somebody that's at a certain point that
[ __ ] will get awkward but boy you got
that chair you say hey let me uh let me
introduce your ass to a little bit of
peace right here and then you sit their
ass down into a chair and that's crazy
think about that somebody even invented
a chair think about that like a long
time ago everybody was just standing
around people just standing around like
now what and then finally you know some
straight up I'm gonna be honest hero
came along and said tada
and everybody was I mean that must have
been like it must have been like a like
marijuana almost at first just putting
your bud and you're letting your thighs
on to a just a place to rest them oh can
you imagine can you imagine that you've
been standing up for years you've been
standing up for years your family your
father's been standing up your
grandfather has great posture
everybody got spa stir because they've
been standing like a [ __ ] and
then suddenly out of nowhere some some
beautiful little carpenter some dirty
little wood martyr comes along and just
chisels out a damn seat and you set that
ass into a chair for the first time mmm
I mean I bet semen just leaks out of
your pores can you imagine how good that
feels
just that full-body [ __ ] you know just
coming out of your hole just out of your
pores just
or just a man imagine seeing watching
your grandfather sit down for the first
time just so the tears that would come
out of his eyes after being a lie
you know because in those in the old old
old days I'm talking you know back when
people probably did barely just had
necklaces and stuff like that people
barely had it even a lot of ideas just a
lot of necklaces and just you know a lot
of undercooked meat in those days and so
everybody's been standing and then
somebody comes along and makes a chair
you even fathom that feeling that first
seat just take a sit bro just take a sit
huh and watching your grandfather who's
been standing up his whole life which at
that time was probably you know senior
citizens were 40 years old back then you
know if you weren't like about 45 you
were gonna die of the elements her
yellow fever you know um
lightning lightning killed way more
people back in because you didn't have
houses think about that like right now
yeah there's lightning out there you
don't even know it back in the old days
if there was lightning okay if the lords
were shooting straight up fireworks at
your scalp you knew it but imagine a
your grandfather you know 40 year old
grandfather because yeah by 45 who's
gonna be dead a fever or wolves wolves I
mean in the old days think about how
many wolves probably got 25% of the
population wolves but imagine him does
he's been alive for 39 years you know
and he gets to sit down for that first
time in a chair and just
and that's beautiful good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one